E
OF THE 2020 ELECTION.
WE WILL GO THROUGH THAT TONIGHT.
FIRST WE BEGIN WITH BIDEN'S
FECKLESS POLICY AS IT RELATES TO
THE WAR ON UKRAINE WAGED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE DRAGGED HIS FEET ON MAJOR
SANCTIONS, DRAGGED HIS FEET
UNBLOCKING RUSSIAN OIL IMPORTS.
DRAGGED HIS FEET ON THE LEGAL
AID NEEDED BY UKRAINE, DRAGGED
HIS FEET ON RESUPPLYING
UKRAINE'S ARMY WITH AMMO,
JAVELINS, STINGERS, AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS, AND NOW HE'S DRAGGING
HIS FEET ON THE FIGHTER JETS
THAT UKRAINE DESPERATELY NEEDS
THAT POLAND WANTS TO GIVE THEM.
HE VETOED IT.
AS A RESULT, UKRAINE IS NOW
STRUGGLING TO DEFEND ITS SKIES
AND THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT
CIVILIANS ARE NOW BEING MURDERED
WITH RUSSIAN BOMBS EVERY SINGLE
DAY THAT JOE BIDEN IS DITHERING
AND WAITING, IT MEANS MORE
INNOCENT, MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WILL DIE.
HOW MANY MORE MASS GRAVES DO WE
NEED TO SEE BEFORE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT IS TARGETING CIVILIANS?
WE ARE ALSO WITNESSING A MODERN
DAY THE HANDS OF AN EVIL,
MURDERING THUG.
WHY SOME PEOPLE DEFEND HIM I
HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT AS SPEAKER GINGRICH, WHO
WILL JOIN US IN A MOMENT, POINTS
OUT, "BIDEN SAYS NO TO UKRAINE,
ZELENSKYY, AND KEEPS AMERICA IN
THE BACKSEAT."
SO MAKE NO MISTAKE, WHAT HAPPENS
IN UKRAINE WILL HAVE
CONSEQUENCES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
AND YOU BETTER BELIEVE THAT
OTHER HOSTILE REGIMES LIKE
CHINA, THE MULLAHS IN IRAN, THEY
ARE WATCHING, ALL WHILE JOE IS
FORGING AHEAD WITH HIS IDIOTIC
NEW NUCLEAR DEAL WITH IRAN.
STILL BEING NEGOTIATED, BELIEVE
IT OR NOT, BY RUSSIA AND CHINA.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
OR AS THE NATIONAL REVIEW PUT
IT, "BIDEN CAVES ON SANCTIONS
OVER RUSSIA'S WAR CRIMES AGAINST
UKRAINE TO PRESERVE RUSSIA'S
SPONSORSHIP OF TERRORIST IRAN'S
NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
EITHER WAY, PUTIN MAY GET A
$10 BILLION NUCLEAR FACILITY
THAT HE BUILDS IN IRAN OUT OF
THIS DEAL ACCORDING TO REPORTS.
SO AN IMPORTANT QUESTION
TONIGHT.
HOW CAN ANYONE ON EARTH ACTUALLY
AT THIS MOMENT BE TRUSTING
RUSSIA TO BROKER A DEAL WITH THE
IRANIANS AND OUR COUNTRY?
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH I'M A
THIS IS MADNESS, THIS IS
INSANITY ON A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
BACK TO RUSSIA'S INVASION.
IF UKRAINE IS ABLE TO WIN THIS
WAR, IT WILL BE IN SPITE OF
JOE BIDEN, AND IT'S A BIG "IF"
BUT THE BENEFIT WOULD BE
AMERICA'S ENEMIES HOPEFULLY WILL
START THINKING TWICE BEFORE
WAGING FUTURE CONFLICTS.
I DOUBT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
OUTCOME BECAUSE THEY SEE A WEEK,
FRAIL COGNITIVE MESS IN
JOE BIDEN.
THEY DON'T SEE THE SMARTEST
PERSON IN KAMALA HARRIS, AND
NANCY PELOSI HAS HER OWN
COGNITIVE STRUGGLES.
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
THE POLICY OF REAGAN AND TRUMP,
AND THAT'S PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
AND AGAIN, I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
STARTING WORLD WAR III.
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD
AMERICA EVER PUT A SINGLE BOOT
ON THE GROUND, SHOULD WE HAD ALL
EVER ENFORCE A NO-FLY ZONE.
THAT'S A NONSTARTER.
WE SHOULD HAVE LEARNED A LOT IN
THE LAST 20 YEARS IF NOT THE
LAST 60 YEARS.
WE CANNOT AND WILL NOT BE THE
WORLDS POLICE FORCE, AND I HAVE
SAID THIS FOR DAYS.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO GET OFF HIS
ASS AND GET UKRAINE THOUGH MIGS,
LET POLAND GIVE THEM THE MIGS
AND ANYTHING ELSE THEY NEED
MILITARILY.
THEY SEEM VERY WILLING AND ABLE
AND CAPABLE OF DEFENDING
THEMSELVES WITH THE RIGHT
EQUIPMENT.
AND INSTEAD OF JOE'S VETO OF THE
POLE AND MIGS, HE NEEDS TO GET
OUT OF THE WAY AND LET EVERY
COUNTRY DO WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
THIS IS EUROPE, IF THEIR
BACKYARD.
THEY SHOULD HAVE A GREATER SENSE
OF URGENCY OVER THE U.S.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THIS WON'T
ESCALATE INTO RUSSIA'S INVASION
INTO A GLOBAL CONFLICT.
LET ME JUST -- LET ME GIVE YOU A
LITTLE HISTORY HERE.
DURING THE KOREAN WAR, THE
VIETNAM WAR, MAYBE YOU DON'T
KNOW THIS, THE SOVIET UNION AT
THE TIME, THEY SUPPLIED
NORTH KOREA AND NORTH VIETNAM
WITH DOZENS OF FIGHTER JETS.
AND BY THE WAY, DIDN'T LEAD TO A
WORLD WAR.
DIDN'T LEAD TO A NUCLEAR
HOLOCAUST.
RUSSIA ALREADY SET THE STANDARD
FOR MIGS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T SEEM TO
HAVE A FIRM GRASP ON HISTORY OR
FOREIGN POLICY.
WE ARE BEING LED BY TRULY
INCOMPETENT PEOPLE, STUPID
PEOPLE.
THIS IS BAD FOR THE WORLD, IT IS
BAD TO HAVE A WEAK UNITED STATES
PRESIDENT BUT TODAY THE
PRESIDENT TOOK TIME OUT OF HIS
BUSY SCHEDULE TO REASSURE WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HE'S NOT
STUPID.
SEE IF YOU BELIEVE HIM, YOU
DECIDE.
>> President Biden: BLESS ME,
FATHER, FOR I'M ABOUT TO SIN."
[LAUGHTER]
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW, I MAY
BE IRISH, BUT ARE NOT STUPID.
>> Sean: THAT IS SO
REASSURING, ISN'T IT?
DESPITE WE JUST HEARD, I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT BEING IRISH AND
STUPID HAS NO CORRELATION -- IT
IS ST. PATRICK'S DAY -- EVEN
THOUGH JOE BIDEN IS BOTH.
OVER ON CAPITOL HILL, IT'S EVEN
WORSE.
TODAY NANCY PELOSI MADE A
VALUABLE CONTRIBUTION TO UKRAINE
WITH A DRAMATIC READING OF A
POEM WRITTEN BY BONO.
ALTHOUGH SHE DIDN'T QUITE SAY
BONO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> U.S. HISTORY, LATER -- MAYBE
YOU MIGHT WANT TO WATCH, I'M
GOING TO BE READING A POEM
WRITTEN BY BONO.
ABOUT UKRAINE WHICH YOU MIGHT
FIND INTERESTING.
BUT IN SORROW AND FEAR, THAT'S
WHEN SAINTS CAN APPEAR.
TO DRIVE OUT THOSE OLD SNAKES
ONCE AGAIN AND THEY STRUGGLE FOR
US TO BE FREE FROM THE PSYCHO IN
THIS HUMAN FAMILY.
IRELAND'S SORROW AND PAIN IS NOW
THE UKRAINE AND ST. PATRICK'S
NAME IS NOW ZELENSKYY.
>> Sean: WOW.
DESPITE WHAT IT MIGHT SEEM, NOT
EVERYONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS BEEN IN THE WASHINGTON SWAMP
FOR 150,000 YEARS.
IN FACT THEY ACTUALLY TAKE THEIR
MARCHING ORDERS FROM THIS NEW
PERSON, THE REAL SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI'S SPEAKER IN
NAME ONLY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WOULD HAVE A CRISIS OF
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
AND BLACK WOMEN IN EIGHT STATES.
TODAY I WANT TO DISCUSS PART OF
THIS CRISIS THAT IS ALL TOO
OFTEN OVERLOOKED, BUT WHOSE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THERE'S A
VERY, VERY MEANINGFUL CONNECTION
HERE.
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN FOSSIL
FUEL EXTRACTION SITES AND
OBJECTIONS AND MURDERS OF
INDIGENOUS WOMEN ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: FOSSIL FUELS,
ABDUCTIONS, AND MURDERS OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
OKAY.
CONGRESSWOMAN AOC AND A FEW
OTHER CLIMATE CULT
ECO-SOCIALISTS IN CONGRESS, THEY
ARE CALLING THE SHOTS NOW IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT'S WHY JOE BIDEN WON'T DRILL
AND DO THE THINGS THAT WE COULD
DO TO BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
HE'S A COWARD THAT IS NOW
REFUSING TO STAND UP TO THAT
PERSON, HER SQUAD, AND THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC NEW GREENDALE
RADICAL SOCIALIST PARTY THAT HE
IS LEADING.
AS A RESULT, LOW, MIDDLE INCOME
AMERICANS, THEY ARE SUFFERING
SEVERELY ECONOMICALLY, 40 YEAR
HIGH IN INFLATION CAUSED THAT.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE
ABOUT THOSE AMERICANS.
MIDDLE-CLASS JOE, THAT'S ALL HIS
SHTICK, THAT'S A LIE.
BECAUSE IF HE CARED HE WOULD
MAKE ENERGY -- HE WOULD MAKE
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE A TOP
PRIORITY.
HE INHERITED IT FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
HE ONLY SEEMS TO CARE ABOUT
HIMSELF AND HIS FAMILY.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT A LEADER.
I THOUGHT DON'T ACT HE KNOWS
TODAY IS THURSDAY.
HE'S A SELF-INVOLVED CAREER
POLITICIAN SICKLY TAKING TALKING
POINTS FROM HIS STA